Picture This Christmas time rolls around
you don't have a debt in the world
you've paid off your car you've paid off
your student loans you've started
stacking up just because you've worked
extra so you've moved quickly and you've
started stacking up some savings maybe
you've got five or six thousand stacked
up you're going into Christmas you're
buying presents and the whole thing is
so peaceful you didn't have to get
caught up in the student loan drama or
you know or in the fall back in October
and September and you're going into a
new year completely debt free
you're having savings set aside and you
have completely changed your financial
Outlook how would that feel
come on now